all right we've been talking about it
all hour and it's here there's a free
concert tonight featuring several
talented young musicians with the
Henderson Symphony Orchestra behind him
joining us here in the studio the
conductor of the orchestra Alexander
Aries great to have you with us
Alexandra hi mate so good to see you and
this is Aspen Stevens she's one of the
solos tonight Aspen thank you for coming
in this morning now before we hear you
play a little bit I wanted to talk with
Alexander about the young artist concert
this has been gone for quite a while
right yes it's actually based in our
competition we have a young artist
competition right that has been for more
than 28 years so basically almost 30
years of a young artist competition at
the Henderson has been promoting yeah
and this and this is the result the
concert is the result of the it's
tonight so these kids audition and
they've been rehearsing they have they
have been rehearsing for two weeks and
tonight 7 30 is the final concert yeah
so this is going to be at the Pinecrest
Academy Sloan Canyon campus that's down
there by the Raiders complex and we'll
talk more about that but Aspen I want to
ask you what are you playing tonight and
are you nervous about being with an
orchestra
playing Symphony espanol by Lalo and
it's it's gonna be a little nervous but
I think I think we're ready so what
grade are you in I'm a freshman and
where do you go to school Shadow Ridge
High School and I'm guessing they have
an orchestra program yes but it's got to
be different playing with your student
Orchestra and then with the Henderson
Symphony Orchestra tell me about those
rehearsals and how's that been going I'm
guessing that Alexander has some maybe
suggestions or maybe a little louder
here a little softer here or stuff like
that yeah she's really good about
working with a young
artist and
helping us like it's like we're
comfortable with
um because most of us have never done it
before right do you know any of the
other kids that are playing tonight I've
met them but I didn't know them like
previously okay okay well would it be
okay if we ask you to play a little bit
of what you're going to be playing
tonight all right ladies and gentlemen
here's Aspen
[Music]
wow that's incredible it sounds like
this is not your first time playing the
violin
how long you been playing eight years so
they had to have like a smaller violin
for you because you had to be a little
bit shorter a few years ago right yes
well so Alexandra tell us again about
the concert tonight what other pieces
are we going to hear what other
instruments are the students playing so
we have four
artists and we are going to have piano
we are going to have another a junior
category with Lucas playing the violin
as well and we have uh Alexander playing
the oval so it's a variety of
instruments and we also will have a
little bit of Mozart and Beethoven as
well with Orchestra only that is
wonderful so you can go to Henderson
symphonynv.org to learn more exactly the
tickets are free down at the Pinecrest
Academy Stone can Aspen nice to meet you
and congratulations great job Alex early
great job seeing you again yeah good to
see and